these are some of the boys relieved to
be going home
after the school raid in which many of
their friends were taken hostage
they're leaving behind parents anxiously
waiting for the return of their missing
children
sincerely speaking we here in katsina
state are in a terrifying condition
we don't see the value of the government
in fact i have a younger brother
and a child taken along by the
kidnappers i am from danja
katsina state and i have been in this
school since dawn
and yet there is no update
it's not clear how many children have
been abducted from the all-boys boarding
school
nigerian police say they forced the
gunman to retreat
after engaging them in a shootout for
more than one hour
but there's anger that six years after
more than 270 girls were kidnapped by
the armed group
boko haram at chibok nigerian security
forces appear to have once again
failed to keep school children safe for
rates to be
that we have a major
tragedy of abduction of hundreds
and hundreds of students once again in
the country
is an indication that we learn no
lessons
from the previous tragedies there is
something called the safe school
initiative
this government should ask itself how
seriously
it has taken that initiative abductions
have become increasingly common in
nigeria
just two days before the school
abduction a village elder along with 20
others was kidnapped in the same state
the governor has ordered the immediate
closure of all boarding schools
while investigations are underway
barbara angopa
al jazeera